hey what's up this is Chris D'Elia I'm
trying to this is my audition tape for
Guy Ritchie movie guy Ritchie is putting
out is coming out with the new movie
about gangster British gangsters and so
I'm going to I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
do my audition tape and see what you
guys think of it and then this way this
way I'll send it in maybe I will maybe I
won't depending on what you say alright
here we go
all right [ __ ] listen up all we gotta
do is go into the [ __ ] bank with our
guns [ __ ] out like this Shh we don't
[ __ ] pull the trigger
we just [ __ ] show them the guns all
right and when we do they get scared
when I get scared that's when I give up
the [ __ ] money all right now are you
[ __ ] in or argue I told me what knob
and then the other guy says well I just
you know he starts to say something that
kind of knows it now [ __ ] listen it's
a [ __ ] simple thing all right
or you [ __ ] mean or are you [ __ ]
oh I don't have time for [ __ ]
bollocks and dilly-dallying over this
[ __ ] around I want a [ __ ] talk to you
not a [ __ ] a doubt are you in or are
you out
then that's what and then he says I
don't know
really do you not know let me ask you a
[ __ ] never question are you a [ __ ]
man or are you a twit think about that
one so let me know what you think that's
the scene I might send in for the new
Guy Ritchie movie but I don't know I
won't send it in until you until I get
approval where so let me know thanks